does getting long in the tooth bring you
closer to the truth true you're more
likely to lean right if you have to pee
five times a
night for me it's four according to the
Wall Street Journal as you age you
become more conservative because the
more you learn the more you wise up you
also become more likely to consume
relief Factor by the
truckload researcher says you make more
money and acquire more assets you're
going to prefer more conservative
policies like lower taxes that help you
protect what you earned which will
enable you to give a generous tip to
that nice young man at
Applebee's but also you live long enough
to see that none of the Democrats
promises ever come true and that you
acrew these things through hard work and
savings and not from stealing it from
your child's college
fund and as you pass middle age and
approach retirement eventually you'll
start to lean right and not just because
of the hip replacement stability trumps
change which is why liberal policies
that destroy social order aren't popular
with folks who've spent decades building
a foundation for themselves and their
families so what's this mean for 2024
well if you can't tell by the
commercials on this channel Americans
are getting
older their idea of a green New Deal is
a fresh shipment of balance of nature
veggie
capsules of course we'll also need
pillows and ointments and most of all
gold birth rates are down and the
average age is going up that's a sizable
voting base for Republicans so get their
votes now because once they die they'll
vote
Democrat you know Lee uh I had a number
of bad ideas when I was young I grew out
of them by being exposed to their
results it's that old line a
conservative is just a liberal mug by
reality the problem is we're not reality
isn't doing much mugging anymore we need
reality
muggers I think that might be starting
recently I mean I here in New York we
saw during our campaign the the younger
voters were concerned about crime in
public safety they had to be right and
you see what's going on in the world
overseas and then when you start think
like what's the most important issue
that's facing America now you know
instead of John Kerrey lecturing you
that it's about you know climate change
and whatever he's pushing on the global
stage or Al Gore times have Chang a bit
but conservatives need to speak to these
young voters when when I went to these
places to talk to the students they're
they're listening mhm but I don't think
L Republicans are even showing up and
part of it is showing up in person but
it's also on social media they're not
getting their news from traditional news
sources they're getting it maybe from
you know Snapchat one year and then five
years later it's some new social media
platform so I I feel like Republicans
conservatives are not engaging well
enough through the you don't think you
don't think Mitch McConnell has it in
with the the kids I I think by the way
you know to your theory I wish that you
know Maxine Waters and Nancy Pelosi and
some of these others who have aged uh
had found a conservative bent somewhere
along the way but uh that's not the case
and they look up you know like these
these Democrat leaders they're still
getting the votes Joe Biden still
getting the votes but I think that
there's an opportunity for young fresh
conservative ideas and relatability to
show up and uh and I think that they're
listening we saw it in New York last
year all right you know uh Jim I have an
idea all right you know where real where
truth comes comedy comedy is where you
hear truth people love going to comedy
clubs and you listen to somebody say
things that they're thinking but can't
say why don't they teach comedy in
college wouldn't that make a like God it
would probably be terrible wouldn't it
oh yeah the you couldn't last I I
remember in like 1995 I said the word
chick on stage and they withheld my pay
because they said I was sexist they said
I was sexist cuz I used to have a joke I
had long hair down to here and I said I
got pulled over on the way here and the
cop goes you know why I pulled you over
I go cuz I look like a chick it was just
a stupid opening joke and they withheld
my pay and W were going to pay me
because they said I was sexist and this
is in 1995 so imagine what we'll go on
now on a college campus that's why no
Comics really do you know colleges
anymore they know yeah is that hilarious
used to be a profit center now it's not
worth it yeah it's not you don't even
you don't even go there but I mean I was
like this when I was younger too cuz I
lived in the city in a shoe box and I
thought I had all these crazy ideas I
was going to change the world and then
when I got older I moved to the suburbs
I had to start paying taxes I'm like why
is my money going here this is
ridiculous this isn't my cause so I get
it but then again they say as you get
older you get more conservative then Joe
wouldn't Joe Biden being in Qin on
yeah maybe he is Qin on his brain went a
long time ago Katie if this is true that
the older you get the more conservative
you get isn't there some kind of
shortcut like an HOV lane to speed the
process up like a transfer of wisdom
that like gets directly to the source
maybe a shot of some kind I don't know
I've always called myself a grumpy
Millennial because I've never been a
liberal I guess that makes me wiser than
all of the people in my generation the
problem is we keep bailing these people
out like they're paying for their
student loans they're living with their
parents till they 35 they're paying for
their all of their bills so the whole
process of having reality mug you
literally sometimes in New York or
Washington DC isn't happening and so
people aren't actually growing into
being more responsible which means being
a conservative yeah were you ever a
leftist Emily liberal you a you were a
defense attorney correct yes that was
during the hiring freeze in California
of all the Das Ah that's right that's
right so you're a diversity
hire no I don't even know whatever we
had we had our holiday party at Raiders
stadium while I was cheering they
totally loved me anyway um wait I had to
tell you too because I actually took a
comedy class at NYU I was a visiting
student like I took a semester um at
during the summer and I took a a class
on Comedy wow it existed but that was
back in 19 nine no I mean I I don't even
know what I learned
um to your point yes I think the problem
with the headline is not that age makes
you more conservative it is that
experience makes you more conservative
because you are mugged by real because
you are earning your money you're seeing
you're parting with your effort and
labor you're seeing the fruits of all of
your work and you're seeing it for the
most part going because you're seeing
high taxes that are going toward a bunch
of recidivist felons out on the street
and crime everywhere and I just think
what what's so terrible about all of
these kids running around in la la land
like Joe Malone's son that you know
started the Harvard letter and whatever
it's the Upper East Side effect um is
that how many congress people and Mayors
have we seen that have now gone back on
their word about to defunding the police
yeah you know their bloody nose and
their black eye we need more police
force the whole point is that they get
to turn around and turn back on their
statements now that they've seen the
light that crime yes hurts violence is
terrible but that it's preventable but
what's not what what is impossible to
claw back are all the lives lost because
of those idiots so the the problem is
all of us that sit on this side and have
just frankly Common Sense see the
mistakes that are being perpetuated at
the cost of human lives that's the
saddest part it is the saddest part
apparently that comedy class did not pay
off all right up next a Dem from the Len
Star State who likes to Bak hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else